i was so nearly sick then it was a joke
[Music]
saturday people should play rd this is
snack wars for lab bible uk versus
australia i know i'm big down under so
it'll be exciting to see you in this one
all right then all right then you look
went straight in
yeah i'll try this one first
that's good though and it's like nine
percent sugar free
it's not like it's gonna taste like good
this is a beer as well though
that is disgusting to take that away now
yeah we'll take the australian one every
day then we have one meal for australia
can i eat this again
okay i hate those things i
hate these disgusting
so let's see if you've got chewy
chocolate flavored jelly beans
i don't know how i feel about that
and then they go i don't even know how
you pronounce these licorice all sorts
yeah not hard to pronounce at all is it
i am i don't get nervous and i really am
that tastes like what the club i'll go
to with brighton smells like
i swear down yeah
that's what that smells like that was
disgusting sorry
why is this the taste is still i can
smell them can we get them away
can we just get them away
[Applause]
these are gonna be disgusting as well
there's no way i'm going to swallow that
neither of you get points for that that
was
terrible okay
okay barbecue shapes i'm going to like
these i could tell
so pork scratches yeah say nothing
you start with these ones here same
puppet
[Music]
you never tried them and they stink
i've never tried them
but you know when you feed your goldfish
is that one piece
[Music]
i was so nearly sick then it was a joke
wow
[Music]
but juice came out it was crunchy it was
squidgy
i don't know what just happened inside
my mouth but i feel violated
that was such a relief
yeah man pick up australia so you
already know it's been your boy rd snack
was for that bible yeah uk versus
australia
australia you got one yeah you look at
much more banging food the fact that
food scratching still exists in this day
and age should be absolutely illegal and
anybody that still eats them should be
locked up
for life to minimum
no that's not nice man
that is not pleasant at all sorry sorry
sorry is everyone chilling i'm sorry
you want me to eat this this is horrible